et pour parler du liban françois el
bacha en direct de beyrouth il est
économiste et fondateur du site
d'information libnanews
bonsoir françois lebas chat merci de
répondre à nos questions vous êtes donc
à beyrouth
quelle est l'ambiance ce soir à ce qu'il
ya de nouvelles manifestations bien ce
que c'est un calme précaire qui règne
dans les rues de la capitale libanaise
des manifestations il y en a toujours
bonsoir tout d'abord les manifestations
comme je le disais on a toujours
aujourd'hui il ya une manifestation à
nouveau des familles des victimes de
l'explosion du port de beyrouth devant
le tribunal devant le palais de justice
de la ville
donc c'est un mouvement qui est continu
il ya des manifestations aussi en raison
de la dégradation des conditions
sociales et économiques de la crise que
traverse ce pays donc il n'ya pas de
raison pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
manifestation aujourd'hui
saad hariri a présenté tout à l'heure
une équipe dirigeante à michel aoun
conforme je cite à l'initiative de paris
selon ses mots véritable changement ou
bien on prend les mêmes et on recommence
pour le moment il ya peu d'informations
qui circulent concernant la composition
exacte de ce gouvernement donc on est
dans l'inconnu
on peut pas dire qu est ce de quoi il
s'agit on nous fait dire que ce
gouvernement est composé de 24 membres
on connaît donc grosso modo les grandes
lignes dans le 4 mai aps un tiers à la
présidence un tiers au premier ministre
et un tiers au hezbollah et amal mais ça
ne répond pas à une des questions
fondamentales qui était à l'origine du
blocage c'est-à-dire que ce gouvernement
en fin de compte contredirait selon la
présidence la république
le pacte national qui est lui stipule
une composition à 50 sous 50 50 entre
communautés chrétienne et communauté
musulmane donc on verra bien difficile
donc de voir
venir politiquement on vous aura très
certainement pour décrypter un petit peu
plus tard quand on aura la composition
exacte de ce gouvernement composé de 24
spécialiste donc le 4 août marquera le
premier anniversaire triste anniversaire
de l'explosion du port de beyrouth
l'enquète pied dont la vue sur le sujet
doit être bennani il ya des
manifestations qui ont eu lieu en l'a
dit devant la résidence d'un ministre
qui a accusé de bloquer les
investigations
est ce qu'un jour on connaîtra
véritablement la fin mot de l'histoire
le fin mot de l'histoire pour le moment
c'est que le port de beyrouth c'était
une zone où tous les partis c'était un
c'est une sorte de gagne pain tous les
partis
donc ils sont tous impliqués ledent et
c'est très difficile et c'est très
difficile ce sera très difficile d'avoir
la vérité pleine et entière le dessus on
a des personnalités qui sont proches du
président de la chambre qui sont
impliqués dessus on a des personnalités
qui n'ont par exemple son bras droit
directement commencer un ministre des
finances qui aideront la dont l'immunité
est également demandé la levée de
l'immunité est également demandé pardon
par le juge
on a une tête des personnalités proches
de saad hariri le premier ministre
désigné qui sont impliqués de sedan dont
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
norad machenaud et le directeur à
l'époque de l'explosion du port de
beyrouth hassan corail tél donc c'est un
dossier potentiellement explosif pour
tout le monde et vu l'état dans lequel
est là la justice libanaise qui est très
politisée on peut se poser beaucoup de
questions sur le résultat au final et on
a vu ce que cela donne par exemple
concernant les dossiers d'assassinats
qu'on a vu ces dernières années et même
avant le tribunal spécial pour le liban
a accouché d'une souris
comment les libanais
vive t-il concrètement parce que d'après
l'unicef 50% des libanais vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté et 30% des enfants
sautent un repas par jour la situation
est ce qu'elle peut encore s'aggraver ou
est-ce qu'il ya peut-être de l'espoir
avec ce gouvernement donc présenté tout
à l'heure par par saad hariri
dans quel état d'esprit est ce que vous
êtes vous françois lebas chat je pense
qu'on arrive aujourd'hui au creux de la
vague en fait donc je ne vois pas qu'est
ce qui pourra encore être pire on a eu
une bonne nouvelle aujourd'hui parce que
le fonds monétaire international va
verser d'ici demain à 860 millions de
dollars au liban de droits de tirage
spéciaux donc ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle ça va permettre un peu de
gagner du temps mais on a toujours un
coup de gros problèmes qui sont liés aux
7 au secteur bancaire les réserves
monétaires de la banque centrale
disponibles sont pratiquement vides
on a une dévaluation de facto de la
libanaise puisque ces deux là la parité
au marché noir qui nie qui prévaut
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de choses
dans le marché noir qui sont non
rationnels en fait la parité réelle
aujourd'hui est supérieur à est
supérieur pour la livre libanaise par
rapport à priori à la parité du marché
noir
donc est-ce que ses 860 millions de
dollars qui sont attendus ne vont pas
améliorer déjà un peu là la valeur de la
ligue libanais c'est donc regagné un peu
de pouvoir d'achat il faut quand même
préciser que la libanaise a perdu 92
pour cent de sa valeur par rapport au
dollar et que aujourd'hui le salaire
minimum ses 30 dollars et le salaire
médian c'est à dire la moitié des gens
on reçoit à peu près 114 dollars soit
environ 3 dollars 3 dollars ou moins par
jour
merci françois el bacha pour
pour ces explications ces mots forts que
vous prononcez je rappelle que vous êtes
en direct de beyrouth vous êtes
économiste et fondateur du site
d'information libnanews
je remercie